Star Trek 4
is back on the cards
maybe welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and move Channel
[Music]
so this is a very quick video because
I've been speaking to a couple of
friends over at Paramount and it looks
like Paramount do want to push forward
to Star Trek 4 now that the writer's
strike is over apparently the script
needs a bit of work but other than that
they really want to crack on now I think
there might be a few problems ahead
getting a few of the actors back might
be an issue I think Chris Pine Quinto
even Carl Urban won't be a major problem
but I can think of one or two of the
others that might be
Uhura may or may not be in this film
we'll have to wait and see how well they
negotiate with the very in-demand
actress but hey they got it before so I
don't know quite what the contract
situation would be but
there were some issues with potentially
Chris Pine and Quinto being
contractually have an obligation for a
little bit more money that Paramount may
not now want to pay for but again let's
wait and see
so what do I think about them pushing
forwards with this
I thought it made no sense at all that
they were pushing forward to Star Trek 4
and it was announced a little while ago
also this movie now will come under
um secret hideout and kurtzman's
production company rather than Bad Robot
who still has an exclusivity deal with
Warner Brothers I hear that actually a
few months ago there was a brief
conversation between uh Paramount CBS
and Warner Brothers about maybe doing
sort of like a joint thing with the um
movie and where Bad Robot would still be
able to produce it but apparently those
conversations got really complicated
really quickly so it's decided not to go
ahead with that
so it would seem the paramounts are now
ready to push forwards with several big
projects including Star Trek IV that yes
okay scripts may need to be Rewritten
and they're not finalized just yet
but
it does look like it's happening
so we're going to see one more Voyage
with Chris Pine as Kirk we're actually
going to have two different actors
playing Kirk actively at the same time
it's a little bit confused and I can
kind of understand why again according
to my sources there's a couple of
producers over at CBS and Paramount who
think Star Trek is very confused at the
moment and can actually do with a
massive reset and a simplification
but for now let's just look forward to a
movie and a series of movies actually so
far that I've quite enjoyed
and let's see what kurtzman can do with
a theatrical budget
a bit worried about that as well if I'm
honest but let's see
um guys get into the comments tell me
what you think is Star Trek 4 with Chris
Pine Etc something you want to see or is
actually probably a better idea if this
movie series was just left to rest it's
one more complication with an already
complicated Star Trek series we have to
try to keep up with I mean we always
have to keep up with three timelines so
we're gonna have to keep over two
different universes as well maybe
actually three if you believe some of
the rumors about strange new worlds
so
is this all just too bloody complicated
get into comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking of this potential
news if you are new to the channel don't
forget to go over to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first for a small
contribution each month it really
supports the channel you can also go to
scitrack.co.uk that is our dedicated
website where we do articles based on
most of our stories please go check it
out and as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time